the movie The Matrix everyone thinks
science fiction I go no no that's a
documentary everybody got programmed
that's a fact that's a biological
reality but what was interesting they
always say well there's a red pill and
if you take the red pill you get out of
the program and I go guess what almost
everybody in our audience is taking that
red pill at one time change their life
it turns out science has recognized that
when you fall in love you stop playing
the programs and you start creating from
your conscious mind wishes and desires
are conscious mind and so once you let
go of a program and you start creating
wishes and desires it's called the
honeymoon created this heaven on Earth
experience and I go you could have that
every day for every day of your whole
life because we created that and if you
understand you created then you can say
well why don't I create it tomorrow and
I go you can create it every day that's
the beautiful part need motivation watch
a top 10 with believe Nation hey it's EV
car Michael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggled to keep my business going I
had no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories some motivation
today so today let's learn from one of
the best Bruce Lipton and my take on his
top 10 was a success
enjoy rule number two is reprogram your
mind 95% of our behavior is coming from
sub below consciousness
uh and we're the ones that can't see it
when we play it but everybody else of
course is uh seeing exactly what we're
doing so the whole idea is are you
living the life you want or are you
living the life you've been programmed
and the answer unfortunately is most of
us are living the life we've been
programmed and and the programming comes
from other people so it's not our lives
the reason let's give a reason why
programming occurs okay uh the brain is
a computer most powerful computer that
humans have ever experienced but it has
parallels to computers and number one is
this um in the old days when you would
buy a computer before they put the
programs in you could bring it home
brand new computer plug it in push start
boots up screens on and I say do
something and people well no I can't do
anything say you got a brand new
computer now first you have to put
programs into a computer before you can
use that computer the brain of a of a
human is the same thing uh the screen
lights up in the last trimester of
pregnancy it's ready but there are no
programs so the first seven years of a
child's life is the brain is not
operating at the higher level of
Consciousness higher level higher
vibration that's what we talk about we
put wires on a person's head electroen
cograph read brain function a child up
through 7even is not operating at
Consciousness except for a little bit
it's primarily operating at a lower
vibration called Theta and I say what
what is say I say it's expressed as
imagination so that's how uh children
can have a tea part part and they pour
nothing into the cup and then they drink
the nothing and then they explain how
that was the best tea they ever had or a
child rides a broom saying it's a horse
in the child's mind that is not a broom
it's a it's a horse but it's mixing
imagination and reality but Theta is
hypnosis and the significance of that is
children have to learn how to become a
member of a family the rules member of a
community the rules I go how how can an
infant a young kid learn these rules
they can't go to school they can't read
the book and all that and I say you
don't have to Nature provided Theta
hypnosis so that they can observe the
parents the family and the community
just observe their behavior and download
those as programs age seven then that's
when they start to become more conscious
and engaging themselves first seven
years is programming but after age 7 95%
of your life is coming from that program
so if you can program the child for the
first seven years and the rest of the
life of that child is actually an
expression of that program rule number
three is be yourself I was given an
opportunity to go to San
Francisco and have a big presentation at
a big conference on energy and crystals
and stuff like that and I thought well
there's going to be an audience or
energy and crystals like okay this
everything I'm talking about in biology
I was so excited and I thought this is
my great opportunity and it was like
like 3 months before and I thought okay
I'll I'm going to work on this and then
I just let it go I let it go and now
we're getting to a month before and I
said I got to work on my what's my
seminar going to be what's my seminar
and all I had in my head was okay this
was a new Agy kind of thing so I thought
well back then what the heck was new AG
I said oh that's where they wear all
white white shirts and white pants and a
white vest white clothes you know and
that they're so delicate and they speak
in a very quiet tone and they're so new
Agy and that really wasn't me I was like
the bull in the china shop you know it's
like hey and it goes no no that's I got
to calm down I got to be cool I'm going
to present this in a new age fashion so
I tried to formulate a new age me to
present this well now it's about a week
before this conference it's like my new
age me has not come up with any idea of
how to present this and then it started
to get closer it was just a few days
away I'm going to go to San Francisco I
like oh my God I don't have a talk and I
just said forget it let me just be me I
just want to talk the way I want to talk
I'm not going to conform to be some new
age Guru that's not me I'm a science guy
and I'm going to say what I want to say
and finally in that moment it was just a
couple of days before all of a sudden I
said that's it no more new age let's
let's write this and the moment I let go
of some Persona I was supposed to be and
just said n I'm just going to be me all
of a sudden the word started coming out
I can remember I grabbed a yellow pad
and I had a pen and the word started
coming so fast as soon as I said stop
being New Age guys start being Bruce the
words start coming page after page I was
right I had like four or five pages of
notes notes notes notes like after all
those months it was like okay it was a
little constipated in my Consciousness
you know but it all of a sudden freed up
and it's why I am not them I'm
me and try to act like somebody else
took away everything I was and that was
at the point that said oh my God I'm
going to have I'm not going to alter who
I am I Love This research I'm not going
to tailor it for for that audience and
it was so wonderful because there were
three months where it was just logging
back in my head back in my head yeah I
got to do this I do this like didn't
want to do it why cuz at some level the
first thing was I'm going to be somebody
else I'm going to be Mr New Age guy
the moment I let go of being somebody
else and became me then all the words
came down Ru number four is always seek
knowledge a lack of knowledge is a lack
of power and I said you're suffering out
here because you feel you have no power
and if you really understand the biology
that we're talking about and the
spirituality that you're talking about
and you start to recognize it you
recognize oh my God you are so powerful
and yet you have a belief of victim
and since belief controls it no matter
how powerful you are if your belief is
your victim then you are victim and we
have been victimized by beliefs that are
incorrect and uh uh and if we adjust the
science it automatically then comes
right together with the whole spiritual
message that agape and my brother
Reverend here uh have been providing for
years uh but there's a scientific
context to it because a lot of people go
well is it scientific I go yes it
is I mean I mean what what are those
flawed beliefs that that we've been
living under all these years well there
are four of them and two of them are
actually part of darwinian theory which
I'll mention but the first one that's
really important is people have been
programming the belief that the genes
they inherited at conception are
programming the rest of their life the
the genes we didn't select them as far
as we know if you don't like the
characteristics you can't change these
genes and then we add on top of that we
say and the genes turn on and off by
themselves and all of a sudden you start
to realize then I'm not running my life
the genes are running my life oh my God
there's cancer in the family and their
genes are going I'm going to get a
cancer Gene I'm and I say what's the
belief you already got the belief I'm
going to get cancer I go this is trouble
right there right right right right this
little sidebar because I love this
sidebar there's not one gene that causes
cancer cancer is not caused by a gene
cancer is caused by disharmony in your
life uh unresolved anger is the bigest
one uh feeling lost left out you know
not part of something is another one
that separates you and I want people to
understand that because so many people
say oh I've got this cancer and the gene
do and I'm just a victim back here and
the genes took this and genes made this
I go stop you are co-creating with those
genes the gene does not turn on and off
and the gene does not control things the
gene responds to the environment and and
if your perception of the environment is
not in Harmony and support of your life
that disharmony is what can activate a
gene a gene is a blueprint just like in
an architect's office and I mentioned I
say you go into an architect office and
she's working on a blueprint you ask her
you say hey is your blueprint on or off
and she'd look at you like what are you
crazy it's a blueprint on there on and
off I go yes DNA is a blueprint to make
the proteins of the body it cannot turn
itself on and off you need an
architect Consciousness mind is
architect right that turns the genes on
and can modify the read out of the jeans
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is practice
Stress Management Consciousness is
controlling your genetic activity the
when when people follow the fate of a
child adopted into a family where
there's cancer they find that the
adopted child will get the same family
cancer at the same probability as any of
the natural siblings so an adopted child
picks up that gets that cancer but
here's the point the adopted child came
from totally different genetics so it
was not the genetics that pushed that
cancer it was being adopted into a
family where the programming was not
giving them uh wholeness health
happiness uh it's just U stressful very
stressful programming and as you said
stress American Psychological
Association recognizes 90% of doctor
visits are stress related
visits and the we don't focus on the
stress that's like oh a side thing I say
no it's not a side thing it's the number
one thing that is coming from the top
down uh and the genes jeans are
blueprints to make the proteins of the
body 100,000 different proteins like
building blocks okay proteins are
complex molecules and they wear out
proteins wear out all the time so you
have to replace them I said well how do
you replace this complex molecule and
the answer is DNA is a
blueprint to make a protein I go so what
I go well you go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
and I say well I ask her is your
blueprint on or off and she would look
at what are you talking about it's a
blueprint it's so on and off I go
precisely jeans cannot turn themselves
on and off they don't
self-actualize they're controlled by
environmental signals and all of a
sudden oh my god well if the environment
is controlling this then your
programming in the environment your
lifestyle in the environment and all
these other things now become the
primary controlling factor of your genes
not the genes and we have to let go
because when I was programming the
doctors that oh jees turn on and off and
all that stuff I was programming that
people are victims because because as I
said as far as you know you didn't pick
the genes you can't change them they
operate by themselves and so we were
programming victim and then it turns out
the new science of epigenetics is not
victim you're the one that's actually
controlling it with your behavior rule
number six is take control if my
thoughts are distorted because of animal
Soul when I broadcast these thoughts I'm
not activating what I want I'm
activating what the program wants and I
started to realize that because the
magnetic field as you said is shaping
our experiences in this world at this
point and that's what you can read with
Magneto andil graph you're reading these
fields which are your thoughts and then
I started to realize when the field is
being mainly run by the animal
Soul I'm not controlling that that was
the automatic program that's a program
that's not me that's program and I
realized I could observe me doing the
program but there's a point like you
recognize there's a point you say wait a
minute I'm the controller I don't want
that program I want to use my human soul
to run the
show and as you said same thing once you
start coming from the human soul you
override the animal soul that's when you
become the Creator and because of our
creation not only is information coming
in but as the Magneto and seil graph
shows the information going out and I
say it affects the world we're living in
okay that's the experience you have now
but it also goes back to the original
spirit and this is the karma part where
my life experience has
distorted my spiritual broadcast and I
say 'well how how do I get back and I
say it's very simple you just have to
know who you are and this is what you
said and it's true most people have no
idea who they are they think they're
this physical body and I said that's
what I used to think when I was
conventional science but once I
understood the physics and the role of
energy and Consciousness and spirit the
game Chang for me I said wait a minute I
don't want to be animal soul I want to
be Bruce's soul I want brucees to create
this not the not the program from mother
and father and culture I don't want that
one I want one and like you I started to
recognize well wait I can change I can
now I want to take the control now I
want to put my hands back on the
steering wheel I want to drive this I
don't want the program to drive this you
know the cell phone that you have in
your hand yeah yeah you can drive it by
talking into it but it also can work by
itself because it's got program and I
think that you and I have this
information that we've been trying to
present to the world to say take back
the
control because you're more than this
body rule number seven is change your
perception well I could live in a
perfectly healthy happy environment that
will support me but if I perceive it's a
negative environment then my cells
inside my body do not know know that it
is a healthy environment they only see
the perception that I send to them and
this is why perception becomes so
important is because the cells are not
directly touching the environment and
depend on the nervous system's
interpretation to adjust their biology
so if I change my perception my mind
change my belief about life I change the
signals that are going in and adjusting
the function of the cell the point is
very very sign significant and that is
this I'm not a victim of my genes
because I uh by my ability to change my
environment and by my ability to change
my perception of the environment have
the ability to control my genetic
activity I'm not a victim of my heredity
I'm a master of my genetic activity rule
number eight is get into Theta well how
do you change a program that was the
issue not how you change the conscious
mind how do you change the subconscious
mind cuz it does learn conscious mind
learns by just whatever you read the
book I learned it okay uh subconscious
mind doesn't learn that way I say how
does it learn I say well in the first
seven years that's when I said the
programming went in the brain wasn't
functioning at the higher level of
Consciousness it was actually a little
lower that was called Theta the
vibration the imagination and all that
that's hypnosis okay so the first way we
learned programs was hypnosis cuz the
the the function of the brain wasn't it
was at a high at a low you know lower
vibration uh some people might remember
the old days when hypnotherapy they
they'd have a watch and the
hypnotherapist said you know swing the
watch back and forth and they would say
you're getting tired you're getting
tired uh and what was the point when you
get tired you lower the vibration of the
brain and the moment you fall asleep
actually consciously the next level of
activity of the brain is Theta before it
goes down to the lowest vibration Delta
to sleep so every night when you go to
bed there's a period just after you
close your eyes and you're essentially
disconnected for a moment your brain is
operating in Theta well Theta is
hypnosis okay so I said well that's how
you you your brain was in Theta during
that childhood period as predominantly
now you're an adult I said yeah but you
have Theta every night when you go to
bed so I said what can you do and this
is the old story you've heard people do
it you put a pair of earphones on at
night you play a program that you want
to be true in your life you and while
you're awake you might hear the program
but it's the moment you fall asleep the
conscious mind shut off but the
subconscious mind is now in record Theta
so whatever is coming through the
earphones at that moment after you fall
asleep you don't hear it but the
subconscious mind is hearing it and
downloading it in a state of theta so
the first way of changing a belief
system is to get into Theta uh and this
is called self- hypnosis put the
earphones on play the program program
for health happiness love joy whatever
and just go to sleep which is really
cool because you don't have any there's
no studying here you just play the rule
number nine is study the signs of
spirituality I think this is one of the
best things that we both can do right
now is to help people recognize how
truly powerful they are even though
they've been programmed saying I'm a
victim I say no you're not and there's a
science behind it and that's why I love
talking with you because there's the
spiritual part which I never was
spiritual for 40 years I was a Science
Guy genes chromosomes blah blah blah and
then in the study of the cells the cells
taught me that we're not even in here
we're broadcast playing through here and
and when you understand why which was
which blew my mind because hey I wasn't
spiritual and all of a sudden I said oh
my goodness the cells have little
antennas on them and each of us has a
different set of these antennas which
are receiving a broadcast yes in physics
you might say the word field which is uh
let me Define it invisible moving forces
that influence the physical world and I
go same definition for Spirit invisible
moving forces influence the physical
world I said oh my God quantum physics
is revealed to us that we're this energy
spirit and we come in and play through
the body and our each of our bodies have
a different sets of antennas so no two
people get the same station and all of a
sudden I realize oh my God you know
after 40 some years of not even
believing in it in two minutes I turn
around and go of course everything is
spiritual
now the meaning of it for me Michael was
so great because you know what happened
Fe you had a you had a kind of an
instantaneous Epiphany it just changed
your life the lightning hit me yeah and
and what was interesting within seconds
I lost
fear because I understand that because
the greatest fear people have is death
yes what if you don't die because the
field is always here whether the body
which I call the television set you're
watching the Bruce show on the
television set here but the bru show is
a broadcast being picked up and played
through the show and I realized uh you
can't die you're not even in here right
where're the energy around
here and then but then you know being a
inquisitive scientist I I remember I'll
never forget it I sat there just like oh
my God there's a spirit and there's a
body body and a spirit and my science
mind said why not just be a spirit why
have a body and then I found out I had
what I referred to as Jewish comedian
cells because I I asked a question why I
have both a body and a spirit and the
cells answered with a question that came
right up in my head and the answer is
like it's so profound and so funny I
said why have a sp in the body and the
and the cell said Bruce if you're just a
spirit what does chocolate taste like
now you have to take that one in for a
little bit and realize something is that
this
body translates energy environments into
pictures and sounds and smells and
feelings uh and all these things and I
go oh my God we came here to experience
life and number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
participate in conscious Revolution well
the other day I was going through my toy
box and guess what I found something I
had seen for a long long time my
wonderful wonderful ETA sketch now many
of you may have had this when you were
young as well but I really loved it you
know why it gave you an opportunity to
make a drawing on this screen by turning
these dials down here and then after you
complete the drawing you can then Shake
It Up and the drawing will disappear and
you can make another drawing so it was
like a reusable pen and paper uh just
shake it and make a new one so here
let's take a look at how you do it and
I'll try it it's been a long time since
I've done it but uh let me work at it
here's how it
works so well you can see I'm a little
out of practice on it but here's the
beautiful part here's a drawing that I
just made and I created this image and
then manifested it on the screen of the
at sketch so what's really interesting
is what I can do is now shake up this
screen and erase the image and then I
can create another another one perhaps
this one is going to be a little better
than the last one let's see what I can
do this
time well what a great picture but what
we can do is just shake it
up what the hell is going on behind me
oh my God the world is
collapsing so why is this relevant
because there's a lot we can learn about
Evolution through an etes sketch wow
what we're experiencing right now is a
process called Evolution well it's not
the evolution we learned in school the
Darwin version that's the kind of
evolution that says Evolution has
gradual changes over billions of years
imperceptible but over a long time you
see an outcome that's different in
contrast to the old version of evolution
the gradualism version there's a new
understanding Evolution called
punctuated equilibrium uh this is a
theory that was devised by Stephen J
goul and Niles Eldridge and what did
they recognize is that when looking for
for fossils there were different layers
where fossils of animals that no longer
exist and then there's like a space and
then there's another layer with fossils
of animals that no longer exist and then
another space and they said well there's
something going on there's a development
a punctuation another development and a
punctuation the punctuations are natural
events that destroyed the nature and the
Web of Life at that time and in fact the
last one of these mass extinctions is
attributed to a giant Comet that hit
near the Yucatan Peninsula and upended
the web of life and at that last
Extinction 66 million years ago remember
before the comet hit the planet was
filled with lush tropical forest and
dinosaurs after the comet hit they don't
exist anymore the strata that we see in
the fossils is really the same story as
we see in the AES scatch the strata
means that something happened there was
a picture then the picture changed and a
new picture formed on the next strata
and then that picture changed the
understanding about the nature of the
etes sketch and what's actually going on
in our world right now are really the
same story we've created an image it's
not sustainable and and the edes sketch
is shaking but the planet is shaking the
planet is telling us that Civilization
you have created is no longer
sustainable and it's time for us to
create a more thrivable situation for us
to move into the future there's an old
saying there's no such thing as a new
story well in fact interesting point we
can go back thousand years and start to
recognize that the Buddhists were
telling us the same story in a different
fashion they were making what are called
sand mandalas and these are very ornate
Creations from different Sands instead
of paint different sand creating a
structure and then making this most
beautiful structure and they also
recognize just like the universe is
things don't always stay the same so
after they create this most beautiful
expression then they take all the sand
and scoop it all together make a big big
pile and start all over again for
another image just as in the story with
a mandala and the same story in the etes
sketch and the same story that we're
experiencing on this planet right now
there's a very important point that says
that we can move into the future but
take with us what we learn from the past
to build a better future to thrive into
that future and this is where we are
right now shaking it up so that
Civilization come together in a new
version with love Harmony and peace
while we're in this state of it's a very
important point about you the Observer
of what I've just been talking about
like go why is this important because
you represent cultural creatives you are
the people that are looking for answers
to how to get into the future from the
destruction we're facing right now and
the answers are not in the box so just
by even watching what we're talking
about right here is the idea to give you
the Insight of how powerful you are in
creating the new future your
participation is involved in this
Evolution this is not a passive event
you sit at home and wait for evolution
this is where we go out and manifest
Evolution and just like in the story the
etes sketch you can put your hands on
the dial and start to create a new image
as well and so collectively when we all
work together the new image is a new
civilization one that can take us from
today into a future this is the moment
of manifesting a new civilization not
just for the people but for mother
nature herself and this is our
opportunity to participate in conscious
evolution what is the immune system well
generally it's something that protects
me from what from things that get inside
your body and I said well why should
things want to get inside my body in the
first place let's set up a
scenario you're out there in the world
and I drop you off in the wilderness and
I say okay survive and one of the things
you have to do is start finding food and
you're going to spend all your time
maybe find nothing and you're going to
be looking for food and here's an
alternative Vision I drop you out and
eat all you can Buffet well you don't
have to worry about food it's being
served to you all the time what does
this have to do with the immune system I
go like this bacteria parasites that
live out in the environment have to
struggle for their survival defined food
but underneath your skin the tissues
inside your body are flush with fluid
from the blood and in that fluid are all
the nutrients and elements necessary for
growth so if a bacteria could find
itself inside to your body it would be
sitting pretty all it have to do is just
sit there and food would be constantly
delivered from an individual circulatory
system so the idea is well yeah then
obviously this is a nice environment
that uh invasive organisms would like to
find themselves in because it's like
free food what you know no props
so okay so what does this mean it says
well then we have to have a defense
system because if invasive organisms get
in there not only will they utilize the
food we make but they could create a
toxic waste environment that could
actually undermine our health so we
can't afford to have invasive organisms
come into us and take over and the
immune system's job is an internal
protection system as opposed to for
example the adrenal system fight or
flight which protects you from threats
on the outside immune system protects
you from threats on the inside so I said
well how does it work well the immune
system is an intelligent system because
what is the function of the immune
system to go out into the world of their
body and look for things that are new
that came in and then not only recognize
them but learn about them so that they
could create antibodies for example to
effectively knock them out so the immune
system's character is learning and
memory I go wow what a coincidence this
is the character of the nervous system
point the immune system is an extension
of the nervous system learning in memory
about the environment in which you live
so I said well how does it work well I
say that there are organisms that prefer
to find the interior of our body as a
place to live because it's so much
easier for them just to sit there and uh
live off of your energy and your
nourishment so the old story is oh the
immune system uh protects self my body
against invading organisms as everything
else is called not self well I go that's
a crude Insight but it's not anywhere
near accurate for a simple reason the
immune system identifies things that get
into the body that cause disruption of
the system and its job is to identify
them mark them and eliminate them and I
go but there you know there are many
organisms that live with us that are
part of us it's called the micro biome
thousands of species of organisms
bacteria and parasites living with us I
say the immune system doesn't attack
them the reason is this they support our
viability they support who we are so
self versus not self that's not the
discriminating factor of the immune
system factor of the immune system is
anything that's disruptive to the system
well guess what that not only includes
organisms that came from the outside but
even our own cells if they go r
like go into a cancer State the immune
system's job is to eliminate them so
basically the function of immune system
is to keep Harmony in the system any
organism that comes in that disrupts
Harmony function immune system
eliminated the most important aspect
about sleep is that it gives a chance
for the body to re-calibrate its system
so when Consciousness is out then uh the
body starts to balance everything that's
going on you know with each system the
body's pH the temperature regulation
very interesting point that when people
are comos uh they're in a hospital and
they got all the wires on them and
everything they run at a beautiful just
just beautiful like idling speed they're
comos but their body is maintained a
balance and Harmony and everything is
great in the body level but as soon as
they become awake then the parameters in
the body all start to change because
it's our Consciousness that that is is
creating the the functions of our body
uh and it's really important for people
to understand this is that quantum
physics is the most valid science on
this planet in regard to it's
theoretical insights um and the number
one principle in quantum physics is
consciousness is creating our life
experience that's the most important
understanding because it says we're not
just a a machine but we're like a remote
control machine there's a uh an energy
field that is being picked up by each of
us that is different uh the the field
that's being received is different for
each person energy psychology is a new
version of psychology that engages
something called super learning super
learning what's that I go maybe you seen
somebody read a book by moving their
finger down the page just as fast as
they move that finger down the page they
read everything on both you know on the
page on both Pages boom they could just
read it so the idea is this well what if
you can engage super learning and
uh use that in downloading a new
Behavior you ready you can change the
belief you had your whole life 50 60
years you can change that in minutes
because super learning is the equivalent
of pushing the record button on on the
subconscious super learning allows you
to download a new program in minutes and
we need that why because the behavior
that the culture and civilization using
today is so out of harmony with nature
that humans are causing their own
Extinction at this moment it's called a
mass extinction NASA scientists have
have already told us that industrial
civilization the one we're in uh is
facing and I I want to emphasize this
because it was in the title of the
report and I just I said we are facing
an
irreversible collapse of civilization in
the next couple of decades well we're
seeing it right now civilization is not
working the chaos that's all over the
planet is a sign that it does not work
this way and if we don't change then
we're facing our own Extinction negative
thinking is equally powerful but works
in the opposite direction meaning with
positive thinking you could heal
yourself of any disease with negative
thinking you can die and create any
disease you can create your own death
just because you believe you're going to
die and all of a sudden I say well then
it's the power of belief positive or
negative that is shaping the world and I
go well this is why when we look at
people's beliefs and and they they do
you know an assessment of they find out
over 60% of the beliefs that we're
manifesting every day are negative and
disempowering self-sabotaging thoughts
that we've acquired such as I'm a victim
of my genes that's a belief and somebody
says yeah well I'm going to die of
cancer because it's running in my C in
my family and they get cancer and then
they find out there's no Gene that
causes cancer oh oh I'm I'm saying this
on uh on Lynn show I will have to
emphasize that there is not one gene
that if you have this Gene you have
cancer genes are correlated with cancer
genes are not causing cancer this is why
half the women that have the breast
cancer Gene
brca2 half the women never get the
cancer but they all possess the gene so
where's the point they said the gene
didn't cause it it was a lifestyle that
was not in harmony that ultimately
activated what is called a cancer Gene I
said so what do you mean so if you
change your thoughts you can get rid of
cancer I go yeah well that's what
spontaneous remission is all
about and so um I'm stepping on
Lindfield here because this is where
this emanation of thought and we don't
see it and we don't in our history oh
that's just thoughts and feelings I go
those are the controls
that are manifesting your life your
thoughts and your feelings your feelings
are the translation of the energy into
sensation so your feelings are like a
compass they're telling you whether
you're going toward more life or to less
life what are the main limiting beliefs
that you just hear consistently that
most people tend to have if they're not
in a have a a higher level program that
they've caught and switched with well
one one of the main beliefs that they're
caught up in is the uh lack of power
they feel over their own health and
their own reality that I'm a victim I'm
a victim of my genes I'm a victim of
this world out here I say if you if a
the belief system uh is translated into
Behavior if I believe I'm a victim then
my behavior will be as a victim no power
you guys tell me what to do and I'll try
and do what you just said and I say well
that's the biggest problem of all
because quantum physics I mentioned is
the most valid science and principle
number one is you're the creator of this
it's like well when are you going to own
that and the answer is I could say it
but then you walk away and a few minutes
later you're back into your world again
everything's gone you know listen took
me a while uh I learned and understood
that oh my God this is how it works and
I was so excited I wanted to get people
I want to tell anybody listen to S this
is how it works so I I beginning got
some people together and I started to go
off let me tell you how to create the
most beautiful life experience and then
they'd look at me and they go you know
lip in for a guy who says you know this
your life doesn't look that good
interesting it was my wakeup call that
said how the H can I talk about how
wonderful this is and I'm not practicing
it and I immediately said to myself no
don't go out there and talk to anybody
about this why until you do it just so
what were the what were the things that
were holding you back before You'
discovered this and then what was the
new program that you started to
implement for yourself on a consistent
basis to have a 100% upgraded program
yeah well U one of the things
professionally okay I was doing a great
job I I had a great professorship in a
medical school all that kind of stuff
you know personally my life sucked
really get a relationship off the ground
I go why not I go well now that I know
about it I was programmed about
relationships by observing my father and
my mother well they had dysfunctional
relationship so what do you think I
downloaded dysfunction yeah so my
conscious mind goes forward and says
yeah I want to have a great relationship
I get into it my subconscious mind steps
up and says this is how we do a
relationship you oh uh oh game over you
know why because I didn't see the
negative behaviors that I was putting
out my partner potential partner saw
them and gave them cause for alarm I
don't think I want to be with this guy
you know that was me and then I realized
that and that's when I really had to go
in first thing and start to change who
am I and I'll tell you the biggest
problem now after years of working
people do not love
themselves and I said what does that
mean I said if you have a program where
you don't love yourself then rationally
logically can anybody else love you the
answer is no because you don't think
you're lovable that's right somebody
says you are that oh I love you and then
you go well you know you probably don't
have any quality control I know I'm not
lovable what's wrong with you you know
and then at some point you push them
away and then they're not there then you
go I'm not lovable nobody's here I I
push them away you know and I changed
that I was nearly what 45 years old 40
some years old and I had zero quality
relationships for all that life right I
changed the
program and within a couple of years I
I'm now with my partner
Margaret and and the fact is she was
involved with a um workshop training
program for people so she understood
processing and stuff and when I came and
we added the science and the processing
uh we've been living a honeymoon for 26
years really 2 years waking up every day
going wow still here another day for fun
another day for being in love it was
great and it still is but if I didn't
change the program that would never have
been part of my life at all I would have
been my whole life struggling an
interesting thing about the Matrix is
that we're given a choice to take either
a red pill or a blue pill taking the red
pill wakes us up and the blue pill puts
us back to sleep those that have taken
to Red Pill believe they really have
awakened but the fact is this
biologically speaking how do you know
whether you're really awake or whether
you're still asleep the whole I need to
empower the people because they have
been invisibly disempowered without the
knowledge that their life is coming from
programs that they didn't even put in
there right so true and these programs
rarely support what you want so you play
the programs and all you find is you're
not getting what you want those programs
never gave it to you you know a famous
book uh kosaki wrote a book called Rich
Dad Poor Dad this is truth here is
simple truth if you grew up in a rich
family you were programmed how to be
rich and how to have money if you grew
up in a poor family you were programmed
to recognize you don't have any money
and you don't have any power and I say
then a rich person will stay Rich why
because 95% of the life is coming from
the programs they downloaded from the
rich parents who made all the money the
poor person is going to stay poor
because 95% of their program comes from
the poverty mentality that their family
experienced when they were young
and all of a sudden it says well then
you got programmed you want to be a rich
kid or a poor kid I said well what the
hell was your program
right and the big one that we're talking
about David is the program of fear
because we've all been programmed with
some Vision other people have told us
about the afterlife the fear the hell
the damnation oh I don't want to die I
go hey from what are called near-death
experiences where people have died for a
period of time every almost every one of
them said the exact same thing it was
better out there than it was back here
again and you know because a lot of them
when having this experience are giving a
choice you want to stay here in the
afterlife or you want to go back and
most of them would prefer to have stayed
there but have obligations and came back
right but the point was yeah you're not
this physical body you're the broadcast
you're the energy but when you're
playing through this body then you're
the experiences of your life at this
point when you're out of body you are
the energy and the energy is forever
people don't realize the power
programming I'll give you one right now
cancer is one of the leading causes of
death in in in the world right now and I
go but what I go there's no Gene that
causes cancer what oh well they're enco
genes we call these cancer genes like
the breast cancer Gene I go those are
genes associated with the cancer they
don't cause the cancer for you know
example so many women live in fear of
the breast cancer Gene cuz so many have
it but they live what's the fear I'm
going to get the cancer I have the Gene
and I said that fear is a vision which
is manifesting into their reality but
then I go you know 50% of the women that
carry the gene never get the cancer I
said what's the point the point is this
possession of the gene didn't cause
cancer it was a lifestyle that was
undermining your biology that activated
expression of these genes the gene
didn't activate itself so all of a
sudden it says oh my goodness then the
idea of cancer didn't come from the
genes I go no it came from the
programming programming of disharmony
dysfunction not living in life the fears
that are programmed because our
Consciousness is creating this world oh
that's quantum physics oh yeah that's
upep in genetics oh yeah that's
absolutely right that's Placebo I go
what do you mean I'm sick and the doctor
says this the greatest newest research
pill ever it's going to cure you you
take the pill you get better and you go
oh yeah that was great and then you find
out the pill was a sugar pill there's a
very important point then what the hell
heals you right the conscious belief
that you would be healed manifested
healing and oh yeah Placebo my thoughts
manifested my reality go that's exactly
what it's all about and yet while we are
in a discussion of placebo what people
don't which is much more important to
understand is well positive thinking can
heal us negative thinking is equally
powerful in controlling the character of
our lives so that negative thinking can
cause any disease even death if you just
believe you're going to die you can die
just from the belief of it wow looking
at the world and seeing what's going on
right now all the chaos the upheaval
that's going on is so distressing at one
level and it's interesting for me
because as a scientist I can stand up
and talk about the fact that today's
chaos is a necessary requirement for the
evolution that we would love to see and
yet I like you have to live in this
crazy world it's mind-blowing it's crazy
and it becomes really important because
all of this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by looking at this computer
and watching what's going on around the
world those so-called leaders are not
really helping us get to the destination
of a heaven on Earth reality and it's
time to recognize yes fear takes away
our power I've talked about that in many
many lectures talked about the fact that
stress hormones actually shut down our
Consciousness and puts us into a
reactive mode well this is not a time
for reaction this is a time for creation
and this is what the emphasis of quantum
physics has been telling us that it's
our Consciousness that is making
creation and yet if we're living in fear
and Consciousness is coming from Fear
then what world are we creating well
that's the chaos we observe every day on
the news so in this situation what we
really have to do is just listen to the
words of Franklin D Roosevelt when he
said the only thing we have to fear is
fear
itself also relevant today are the
profound words by Frank Herbert in Dune
where he says fear is the mind killer
and this is what we have to recognize
well I've been talking about the fact
that Consciousness is created our world
and I say it's based on science well let
me give you a very important fact it was
in 1927 in the founding of the science
of quantum physics that we get the most
important Insight from one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics Max
Plank and what does Max say all matter
originates and exists only by virtue of
a force we must assume behind that Force
the existence of a conscious and
intelligent mind he
concludes this
mind is the Matrix of all matter well
that was what 70 more years ago 100
years ago I see has that changed I go no
look at this for example this is an
article out of the most prestigious
scientific journal on this planet nature
and I say what's this article I said
it's called the mental Universe it's by
a Quantum physicist at Johns Hopkins
University I'm not going to go and
describe everything he says in the
article because Richard KH Henry the
author summed it up in the last sentence
let me emphasize for you that last
sentence in this article on quantum
physics the universe is IMM material
matal it's mental and
spiritual live and enjoy the body
provides us with
Sensations pain love joy happiness anger
whatever it comes from this mechanism
it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they they don't see light
back here in the brain they see energy
vibrations sound comes in my ears I
don't hear the sound I hear the
vibrations taste that's a vibration it's
a chemical vibration all of a sudden oh
my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and and I say and this is sent
back to our source so we came here to
have life experiences and I go at that
moment of Awakening I said oh crap
here's the major difference between men
and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive and that's a way of life for
them they're sensitive and then they go
about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program we were programmed to
be insensitive for a very simple reason
you cannot be a soldier if you're
sensitive you can't kill somebody if
you're sensitive so men have been
knowingly programmed to lose
sensitivity so they can be used to do
those jobs like killing somebody else
and I go oh my God then I missed the
reason for being on this planet I missed
the feeling of what is love all about
you know what are these senses of joy
and happiness I'm not allowed to
experience him as a guy because uh that
interferes with a soldier job I go I'm
wasting my life and that was a wakeup
call I said well damn it go out and
taste it and touch it and feel it and
smell it and do whatever you want and if
it's really good do it again and if it
didn't work out so good then don't do
that one again you came here to have
these experiences why would you want to
waste your life having all the negative
fear anxiety all those problems it was a
choice it was
Consciousness but we didn't know that
because we were programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power and as long as
you believe you're a victim then you
manifest
victim and this is why I'm so uh honored
to be with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like falling in love and I go
then what about all this war and
pestilence and plague and and all these
things I go oh that's a
manifestation and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind and
when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
St Peter's going to be there and he says
well
how was your experience in heaven he
said 'what do you mean I saidou were on
earth right that's Heaven why that's
where you came to create what' you
create I
go I don't want to wait till the end
man my my my mother remarried when she
was relatively older and she married
this guy who was I said kogy guy he was
not really happy guy or anything he
lived to be like 95 96 or something he
had cancer my mother took care of him at
home the last week of his life he
essentially wasn't there he was just
comos more or less in the bed and then
two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up he was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any
fun and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's going to die in two days and
he woke up today he didn't have any fun
I said that's not me babe because when I
finish it's going to be that was great
let's do it
again there are three ways to change
belief okay self- hypnosis ear phones on
at night repetition create a new habit
and third one energy psychology which
allows you to rewrite an existing
program in minutes uh and we need to do
this why because if you haven't noticed
and you haven't looked out the window
the world's falling apart they go and
why is it falling apart and the answer
is because we're facing what is called
the six mass extinction of Life the web
of life is collapsing in I go then why
is the web of Life collapsing the answer
is human
behavior I go
oh we don't want the web to collapse we
have to change a
behavior and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time the chaos all
over the world is bringing to light the
fact that these behaviors were fighting
and violently with our behaviors that
have taken us out of heaven and put our
consciousness into a world that we're
experiencing which is falling apart you
want to make a world of heaven then you
change the program and then you could
have Heaven it's your belief system that
that creates this you fell in love
because you stopped playing your program
and you created heaven I say well guess
what heaven was always there except the
damn program gotten away so you want
heaven on
Earth don't play the program stay
mindful or B rewrite the existing
program and put heaven on Earth programs
and there and then 95% of the day you'll
be playing that an adult has all
different ranges of vibrations of brain
function but when a child is born for
the first two years it has a very low
vibration called Delta and a child is in
Delta well adults when they're in Delta
that's called sleeping well yeah for the
first year and a half or two of a
child's life they spend most of their
time in Delta so that's a predominant
vibration of a child's brain but around
2 years of age the vibration of a
child's brain increases at a higher
level of vibration and this level is
called Theta well Theta that's
characterized by
imagination and that's true a child
between the ages of 2 and seven is
mixing the real world and the imaginary
world at the same time so for example
the child's on a broom pretending it's a
horse well to that child that broom is a
horse so if the mother says give me the
Broom the child looks at her like what
are you talking about because the child
really experiences that as a broom oh on
the old famous tea party where they pour
nothing into the cup and they drink
nothing and they go that was the best
tea I ever had well mixing imagination
in the world world is what happens
between ages 2 and seven when a child is
experiencing Theta but by time the child
reaches s the vibration goes a little
bit higher and we call that vibration
Alpha and Alpha is calm
Consciousness well that's the child's
life in the beginning of Consciousness
is very peaceful and loving but then
around age 12 the vibration goes up even
higher now it's called beta vibration
well beta vibration is the brain
activity when a child is in school or
when an adult is working and the
Beautiful part about this is every every
year of the child's life the vibrations
get greater and greater and then when
we're adults we have the whole range yes
at night when we're sleeping it's Delta
and just in the morning before we wake
up called Twilight Ry the brain kicks
into a higher vibration Theta and then
as the alarm clock goes off and we're
ready to wake up the brain is now an
alpha calm Consciousness for the morning
and then on the way to work the
vibration even gets higher now it's
called beta and at work all day long
that's a very high functioning
Consciousness beta you know the
interesting part though is when you come
back home it goes back in Reverse so you
come home from work and you've been
working all day you're in beta and then
when you get home you start to calm down
and relax and the vibration slows down
to Alpha calm Consciousness and then
guess what the moment you fall asleep
and your eyes close the brain is now in
a lower vibration Theta and then as you
go a little deeper guess what Delta and
you're in sleep and every day this Cycle
Works Delta Theta Alpha Beta coming home
beta Alpha Theta Delta cycling and
cycling well this is really a very
interesting aspect of brain function for
this reason Theta the brain activity
between 2 and 7 years old for a child is
not just imagination Theta is
hypnosis and this is how a child can
download so much information as a little
kid under 7 years of age when we
understand the nature of the progression
of our brain vibration it then becomes
important for parents to know this for a
very important reason when does a child
start actually downloading Behavior well
AR interesting fact even before the
child is born in the last trimester of
pregnancy the brain is already beginning
to hit on Theta and when it's doing that
the child is experiencing what the
mother is experienced so a happy mother
is sending happy information to the baby
as programs but a mother who is afraid
frightened not sure of the world she's
living in sends kind of scary messages
to that fetus as it's developing and the
child is actually beginning to download
these messages the mother is Head Start
program she's the one that sees the
world and her interpretation of the
world is translated into programs into
the baby even before it's born and why
should they be able to download So Much
Information well think about it this way
how many rules must a child learn to be
a functional member of a family and then
how many more rules must that child
learn to be a functional member of the
community thousands of rules if you
think about it it for example how a
father talks to his own child is
different than how the father talks to
the neighbor's child which is different
than how the father talks to the mother
which is different than how the father
talks to the neighbor's wife and that's
even different than how the father talks
to the policeman you got to learn a lot
of rules to grow up and be a functional
member of a family and community and the
idea of can you teach this to a child a
youngster they can't read are they going
to go to school no they're kids so the
most important Insight is that a child
between the age of 2 and seven is
observing the community so it's
important for us to all recognize that
around children we really must be
behaving at our best and highest level
because we are now programming the
future of that child the problem is this
when we grow up 95% of our life is
coming from the programs that we
downloaded starting even before we were
born through age 7 and these kids when
they grow up up are going to be the
world that we're moving into these kids
are our future so it really is incumbent
upon us to recognize this we should be
helping them with the best behavior we
must be on our best behavior because
they are copying our Behavior between
ages 2 and 7even especially and
therefore if we want the future to be
better then we have to be better people
as parents as Community as family we
have to be the models that we want these
kids to be because they're watching us
they're recording us and they'll become
us humans have
morality we're supposed to anyway you
know don't kill things okay uh we're
supposed to have
morality but corporations have no
morality they just have a mission how
much money can I make that is the
mission by law of what a corporation is
so I say then that's why they can do
anything let's destroy the environment
if we can make enough money and all of a
sudden you start to see the leadership
of this world is not really caring about
what the individuals want they want to
appease the money making part and then
the laws come down and and if the if it
conflicts with a corporate law then
screw the people let's give the
corporation their due and that's once we
gave up and we said humans are like uh
corporations are like humans and have
the power of a human I go no they don't
they have no morality nothing like a
human at all uh and uh and we gave them
all the power and this is a wakeup call
for all of us it said who's caring for
you you know I love that they always
talk about the friendly
Banker when's the banker friendly the
banker is friendly when you have money
yeah if you don't have money Banker is
not so friendly anymore doesn't care
about you at all you know and I go same
thing pharmaceutical company you got
money we're working with you you I don't
care about you if you have no money and
we lost and so the evolution we're
facing right now says we have been
driven to this by a Minds that have no
uh care for an environment take take
what you want do what you want throw
crap into the water you know all this
kind of stuff dig out the natural
resources every it's
like what's our future if you do this
the answer is it's already happening
Extinction we're not in harmony with
each other obviously and we're not in
harmony with nature and I say well that
you got two choices here follow the
money or follow the
Harmony and right now unfortunately this
is a tug of war and corporates are
winning because fear because once you're
afraid you give up power fear is a
definition I'm not I'm afraid like go
then who's going to help you who's got
the biggest stick yeah who's the one
with the biggest clout let's give them
the power and I'll wait here for them to
fix it and I go they they're clubbing
you over the at this point and we have
to wake up I'm sorry I went on a TI a
little bit it's really interesting to
understand the difference in the
dichotomy between living in love and
living in fear and it's best Illustrated
if I put cells in a Petri dish and I put
nutrients in front of the cells the
cells will move to the nutrients but if
I put toxins in front of the cells the
cells move away from the toxins the
significance is when uh you're in a
growth situation which is really what
love represents you're open because
growth is open to the world and you
assimilate things and that's where
growth comes from protection is just a
complete opposite protection means
you're threatened your life is
threatened and you wall yourself off in
protection so growth is open and
protection is closed well the relevance
is then you can't be in growth and in
protection at the same time so in our
normal history of biology protection is
a necessary part of our survival you
being chased by a saber-tooth tiger you
seriously have to do something about
this so what Nature has done is created
a protection mechanism in scientific
terms is referred to as the hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis very complicated
priated as HPA and what this really
represents is the hypothalamus the part
of the brain that does an interpretation
it looks at the world and says am I in a
safe place or am I in a scary place if
the hypothalamus sees that we're in
threat of any kind it sends a signal to
the pituitary gland the master gland
whose signals coordinate the activity of
50 trillion cells well in the case of a
threat uh the pituitary gland releases
hormones that activate the adrenal
glands the adrenal system is referred to
as fight or flight so it's basically a
protection mechanism so I say okay great
the HPA axis hypothalamus sees the
threat pituitary coordinates 50 trillion
cells and the adrenal gland prepares for
a protection response well if you're
being chased by a saber-tooth tiger
you're going to have to use your arms
and legs to run away or fight what you
need to do so the system when under
threat releases stress hormones from the
adrenal gland the adrenal gland
allocates all the energy of the system
to run away from the saber-tooth tiger
well that means the first thing the
adrenal gland activity does is cause the
blood vessels in the gut to constrict
this forces the blood which has the
energy to the arms and legs but then you
have to realize this the moment you shut
down the blood vessels of the gut this
is where growth and maintenance and the
necessary control and stability of the
body is coming from the organs of the
viscera so when you're in a moment of
threat you shut down the energy going to
this gut because you're allocating the
energy to run away that's one of the
first things that uh happens as we shut
down growth and maintenance of the body
and people say well growth I'm an adult
I don't need to grow and I go we're made
out of 50 trillion cells but every day
we lose billions hundreds of billions of
cells numbers that are just too big to
conceive of actually of normal attrition
aging damage uh and so it basically says
every day you're losing hundreds of
billions of cells that means by
definition every day you have to Place
hundreds of billions of cells so while
you don't see yourself growing every day
you are growing to match what you're
losing so if you shut down the growth of
the system it won't take very long for
the system to become uh in a state of
disrepair because if you're not
maintaining uh the replacement of those
cells this will lead to uh sickness and
disease and number two uh remember when
the threat is present the adrenal uh
hormones of release and stress they shut
down the immune system system and this
is an effort to conserve energy to run
away from the tiger what's the result of
being in a state of protection the
answer is you shut down the growth and
maintenance of the body and you shut
down the immune system both of these uh
if sustained for a period of time will
inevitably lead to uh disease and death
and just to refer back again to the
nature of why Evolution gave us this
protection response to run away from the
saber-tooth tiger but once you run away
from that once you've made it away from
that tiger uh then the system goes back
into growth again so by Nature's
understanding you're only supposed to
use the stress system for very short
intervals of time because it interferes
with the normal functions and then you
look at today's world then we realize
247 365 stress hormones are being
released into the system we read the
newspapers we watch the news we're
concerned about the world and it's
unfolding so what was supposed to be
only used for very short time has now
become chronic and The Chronic release
of stress hormones has resulted in an
elevation of the amount of disease and
sickness that our planet is experience
experiencing right now so the
significance is uh we must recover and
then to recover it says we must get out
of the fear that we live in because fear
kills you're being chased by a
saber-tooth tiger I say you you need
energy to to survive you have to run I
say where's the energy going to go I
said well energy is in the blood that's
what carries the energy I say when the
stress hormones come in because the
tiger is chasing you it does several
things it shuts off the blood flow to
the the gut the viscer all the organs
pancreas stomach intestines I go it
shuts off the blood supply I say why I
don't need to fix and maintain the body
if the tiger is going to catch me then I
don't that's a waste of my energy I want
all the energy go to my arms and legs to
escape so I say stress hormones shut off
the the mechanism of the viscera the
growth and maintenance of the body while
you're being chased I say what else and
here comes the one that you were
bringing up when when we're really sick
you don't have a lot of energy to even
get out of bed because the immune system
uses a lot of energy to keep you healthy
I go so I'm being chased by a tiger and
I have a bacterial infection so I'm
putting energy into Runway and putting
energy into the infection I go why do
you worry about the infection because if
the tiger catches you the infection is
not a problem anymore you're done okay
so the this is the point you brought up
and this is the most important point for
the audience to understand stress
hormones shut off the immune system so
that the energy can be used to run away
from the tiger before being used to
fight the bacteria uh and this is the
most important understanding because
stress is the cause of over 90% of
illness on this planet everyone thinks
genes are causing illness I go less than
1% of illness is connected to genes 90%
of illness is stress because when you
put the stress hormones in what do they
do they shut off the maintenance of the
body they shut off the immune system and
they even shut off the intelligence you
what you mean they shut off the
intelligence say
if the conscious brain the one up in the
front that's connected to you your
person is a slow processor like a slow
computer the subconscious is like a
super fast computer if you're being
chased by a tiger it's not the time to
think of
oh oh I go no no
run and so the stress hormone shut down
the blood vessels in the forebrain where
the Consciousness is pushes the blood
with the energy to the hind brain where
reflex
and reaction no thinking because
thinking is slow so I say so then stress
hormones do three things number one they
shut off the growth and maintenance of
the body number two they shut down the
immune system which protects you from
internal problem and number three they
make you less intelligent and I go look
at the look at the world today the
stress levels are overriding as I said
90% of illness is straight stress not
genetics it's lifestyle it's the fear
it's not living in harmony they don't
have enough good music to bring Harmony
into their world they're they're on
edge I go well that automatically
compromises your
[Music]
health
for 10 more amazing rules from eart to
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there live is always
now uh this seems almost too obvious to
state but uh most people live in a way
that almost contradicts the simple fact
that life